aquí tengo mis ecuaciones del capacitor
una está en términos de v y la otra es b
en términos de y ahora vamos a usar esta
ecuación y hacer un pequeño ejercicio
con ella para ver cómo funciona
voy a dibujar un circuito aquí tiene una
fuente de corriente un capacitor el
capacitor tiene un valor de un micro
farad y el valor de nuestra fuente de
corriente le llamaremos i mayúscula y
luce como un pulso y va de 0 a 3 mil
amperes y aquí regresa de nuevo a 0 y el
tiempo que le lleva a este pulso este
tiempo de aquí va a ser igual a 3
milisegundos y aquí lo que quiero
encontrar es que es vedette y vamos a
usar esta ecuación de integral para
encontrarla aquí vamos a poner nuestra
respuesta
aquí está té y aquí está y aquí está y y
en la gráfica de aquí abajo vamos a
poner de iu-v de té aquí dibujamos
nuestra corriente en el tiempo comienza
en cero luego aumenta luego va hacia
arriba hasta cierto valor continúa por
lo que es un pulso de corriente aquí es
cero
aquí tenemos 3.000 y amperes y aquí
tenemos tres milisegundos y ahora
queremos encontrar vedete y algo que
tenemos que hacer es suponer cuál será
el valor de cero y para nuestro problema
vamos a suponer que de cero es igual a
cero volts lo que significa que este
capacitor no tiene ninguna carga al
menos cuando comenzamos nuestro
experimento ahora veamos tres periodos
diferentes de tiempo veremos el periodo
antes del pulso el periodo durante el
pulso y el periodo después de el pulso
descomponemos el problema en tres partes
la primera parte es antes y lo
resolveremos viendo esto decidimos que b
0 era igual a 0 en el estado antes del
pulso aquí ponemos un cero y decidimos
que y es cero lo que significa que el
término adentro de la integral es cero
lo que significa que 0 + 0 va a ser
igual a 0 y esto es igual a vedettes por
lo que antes de el pulso la ecuación del
capacitor nos dice que el voltaje es
cero ahora veamos el periodo durante el
pulso el segundo periodo de tiempo
durante el pulso así que tenemos que
tener más cuidado b es igual a 1 en 13
por la integral que va de 0 a cierto
tiempo t y cuánto vale y durante el
pulso vemos aquí que es una constante
por lo que aquí escribimos 3 milián
pérez
de tal más no olvidemos el voltaje
inicial cuales vemos aquí y nuestro
voltaje inicial es 0 + 0
ahora resolvemos esto de igual a 1 en 13
por esto estos 3.000 amperes salen de la
integral porque son una constante por la
integral de 0 a t de betao y esto es
igual a b
ahora vamos a poner los 3 milián pérez y
ahora vamos a poner el valor de c entre
un micro farah x cuanto vale esto la
integral de 0 ante de de tao es de
minúscula vamos a simplificar esto mili
es 10 a la menos 3 y micro es 10 a la
menos 6 hacemos más espacio y nos queda
b igual a 3 10 a la menos 3 entre 10 a
la menos 6 nos quedan 10 a la 33 mil por
el tiempo y esto es la ecuación de una
línea con una pendiente de 3000 cuáles
son las unidades aquí tres mil volts por
segundo vamos a graficar esto esto va a
ser una línea que es una rampa con
pendiente constante así iba a ocurrir
durante todo este pulso y nos podemos
preguntar cuál es el valor de aquí cuál
es el voltaje vamos a calcularlo
t es 3 milisegundos de de 3 milisegundos
es igual a 3000 por 3 milisegundos y
esto es igual a 3 por 309 y 3000 y por
esto es 10 a la menos 3 se cancelan y
nos quedan 9 volts así que este valor es
de 9 volts así que el voltaje de nuestro
capacitor durante el pulso de corriente
se va a elevar en línea recta hasta 9
volts y lo obtuvimos de esta integral el
capacitor está integrando a la corriente
a un voltaje que aumenta constantemente
ya encontramos el voltaje durante el
pulso y ahora nos falta encontrar el
voltaje después del pulso que va a pasar
con este voltaje a partir de este
momento va hacia abajo va hacia arriba
se queda igual que pasa vamos a usar
nuestra ecuación del capacitor ahora
vamos a definir una nueva integral que
comienza en el tiempo igual a 3
milisegundos
y cuál es nuestro voltaje a los 3
milisegundos pues 9 volts en este caso a
mi b 09 volts que es para este periodo
de tiempo después de los 3 milisegundos
usamos nuestra ecuación y b es igual a 1
en 13 por la integral de y de tal
de tal más de cero y va a partir del
tiempo igual a 3 milisegundos hasta el
tiempo t el tiempo t se encuentra por
acá en algún lugar aquí conocemos el
voltaje vamos a usarlo y vamos a
calcular el voltaje aquí después de los
3 milisegundos para resolver la integral
vemos que es y de tal
durante este tiempo veamos nuestra
gráfica el pulso está en 0 así que todo
este término de aquí es 0 y que es de 0
pues es 9 volts es donde iniciamos en
este intervalo así que la respuesta aquí
después de que ocurre el pulso es que b
es igual a 9 bolsas lo grafica mos aquí
y básicamente va a ser una línea recta a
esta altura en el nuevo voltaje y es así
cómo resolvemos un problema de capacitor
uno muy sencillo y resulta que
integramos un pulso de corriente y
obtuvimos una rampa de voltaje